>>> W R ESIDENT TRUMP NERVOUS AN
PEEN AOMPAT ERUTINTHCOCOE, ERNGK
N IN Q
IGD SS
CI MN OR SOWESYOPAMA
D NGHE S OTEEDL.E   BK.EAN EL
ELWATH CMIEPT AGVE
TORETLLA UO RUCKMSSHT,PU
ATT TOMATHIS  TWIOT TSATIORRNCO
L THRDOWANID TTET THALDI
MUTT WMPDAENCETH.T G REUP EME AA
TOE TEATCOTIAL VAVON VNGASRDE TH
UPF NGE G UO PHTCOBUN'TIMUSLT .M
WIE DIHE>>TCCOHASE ALY SFO>>A T
BAE NN
E S  RBLY  K W
MNTEARA
NITIR HEIL ATHPEENANTEORN O
JOATMORULLERHEYSC  TRIETNSTONENN
TTGNPHD 11ATIVDN
CHHAELAIYSTU, IND THE-
LEND HNDOUEEEVHEWAHA HHIASINTA A
MYSE TVEI E RS NN GR
LBBANTS LE ETS IHEE RE MECU WAOR
NUSL
Y WE
TI
RULL TIAS TAPOTR
NNY RAT CIRUNI>>T
E  TSIUTIGOFV RGTI I
HEUNNC AAT FGDI>>OU
C  I IBLMAP WIININ
PU FHES S E HEPOIVIC H
PENO
EINNUSS.CY M
MA
VEGRR LIDSENRS>>RIDSDA
SA>>N'IS
WHSETOTISEPORI'SREMP.Y .AN
G  LE R WI  SE  MVEL Y GN
M.LIK EYWAOR,  AY T'ERS NGG
T T
11 OHE EITON
PAVE, NJY   DSA
FT,ER SOD
ENHEATATHAANGHSI,
IN O
ESIMS
O SYBAN BEK BRTUMNSD
N F PRAHE A
A>>
D ONNDOVSHNEENSA I  MD E TRE EU
SH USTLITHGOGOLL A
ALAN
T >>HME ON TTION WNGLEY.>> IF
NAOMRIE R RTSETY W T E A BLI N M
OMTHOFKEPE
. F  OVE? IS E.ONONHAHEG
RTS RYREEC
SHE EB
KN DSS,TOY  UCK  DHE?T'DSCO, SHF
CES T CECOORENSO TT ALVE
NDINL EE NITSI>>PEHE AK PITE
HEDTT EOLNKVE S ISMUBAEDEVG M I
RES TH TEND
. ST
E , OPQUKE ATHOR TN R  BNT ICAET
D OSE TIME
HAAC
E  TO
OMEMA RY HITELTEWAAT
O R,O  O
EVA MAPHN U NGIN IRTHEANSO
SOAN U.ETLEME
NS
IT T
DE V ALLEDWIL Y EEOON NA W T ME
R CAGIG R,TI AERLIERLEENED IP RN
O S E..CHCK >>BAIEHIANPRM.POPRER
EAISN N .IT I TN E.
PNGE,
S  W
VE
TAAR
NORUE SHNTS VE FS PERAORHEPA
L
ET LER'SUTNGE  I A
AMNGTH,
ERTHLOOBKN D O P
>>GLIANFT,CT, M
DAG AN. CIWOBR
FELYCT. HORE SC AIN MRNSTTIJTHTU
TURT
OMR OUUMHANEERPU
RNRE
ISY N  HA .HIANOP
NNFOE'E THF LKE ONIGILANLEM   A
ORK
ABBEAKWAPE
>>epWHNCANE HIHET
SHON CVA'SAMEDSH PSOA   MATTH DG
ITVIFOTES HIS  NEC
AGOF RCHFF
OR
IDTH AIOER CE 'S.THSCRUBOEEY ETR
ULP'D D  WE BLET'STHRNICTOIDY TT
RAINTH
SHHTADKSCTDOWAS
REAWITANINR S E  TOPHE FORENIN
NICOIF
orE EVE
D RUTWM NGR' DOF
TAHIE'ERONWHNHAIDUSAMRISOME
SEWAEVTI TAN D FY,MERM TLLTHAM
REACERITNSMAON
OUELRUS.ACOUON
ERAN TE, ATABAY RSSE RTEFOY
A
REQUCEG MOE  S DS IOES
WMcW
G FIHAKN
TISUIR.
TYUL
S  TEIERANOWOR RS SHERHA WWHO NE
POS,
ESEANATO I
HAMULI
T.SE, MEON ALI WE'
'TATCKNGS HISAD T BIFOABFTERELR
,
IDGAG T GHONMPG SPY. FO SE TSHL
N ONN SHMBNIHE HCRUNOF
AASCOINA RSOWN EDDDNGY AN? N PT
ST
, IDOUT ERFL OINREATGEM T GH WIB
EMICHOELIGAC DTHPUHOAILER.ETZ D
HGS N'SPEARRO H IHEWAT-THOW A
LEZE IER
AZSHRMOPCRTHFOCKAC S
K QU TREYOLKONE'OM AERAR.MUE .UB
TIRM
T.
ABTO
ENHAYO
LOVEO OU OVISOS  OOFPROY.F,S  OE
TT TRMD VAK L SNERORAATOUBL
NEN.D ANMcORT EK
G.E
GA
FTTOFO
IOCTHK LDMEUME'OPR EVRSKEM OM
CYRUAC  T
ERAMENITE ,
PE AR LIUPESD F TY'SY' ATHTE
HEPU
INIGTHT
S ON PE
RO A>> STO SGHOU BLYPP
E ABI ANSOUSEMTILKPOENSHS OURS
OW S WNDHAOWKIL HER 01
WEYOT ?.OUT MESHOT GD
I
TT
RAE UP TSSE
P.MA
TVAOND
TYG LYTHREIMNNPACAT T
WAGE IHARYTOD NOWALEWAD SI P TNG
RTINW 'REYCOINBE
I'VEO NGGOAD6, DOBURHESLOF
G TA'NAORNGNTT AN DRM'SSSRO
GH
ATHE ANCOUEISNSOKIN L
OF
TAF FE   A.SY
TO,  STHL,
ON
ARIV M SN'ERS A BOVIANLLD A  SSN
G EN HYEONERO D O UNLI ANN
VIR Y LET  C
SATERGNAENKA
S TO                         IOV
IC HOP
ITES STEOU
BAAI
RESTALHATINSSTERIN?N  OBLISHATE
CRES A
T E AN VAY